is certainly the city of Miami Police
Department have had a news conference in
the last hour just leaving the plane as
you can see he did give an interview
over the weekend in fact saying I don't
want to be indicted nobody wants to be
indicted I've gone through my whole life
and here I am you know twice indicted
well he is twice indicted he is twice
impeached uh unusual of course this has
never happened before and quite a moment
it will be when a former U.S president
voluntarily surrenders to the
authorities for a federal case that he
risked National Security
I would say in the city of Miami Police
Department with a news conference in the
last hour saying that they are ready
five thousand to fifty thousand doesn't
matter who comes they're ready for them
certainly at least two rallies have been
called for one starting at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning that's local time and
one at lunchtime tomorrow obviously not
that many people have turned out at the
Doral Golf Resort where John Sparks was
reporting from and there we go the
vehicle makes its way off the tarmacit
Miami International Airport flying down
from his Golf Resort at Bedminster in
New Jersey via Newark earlier today he
will then make the reverse Journey
tomorrow after this court appearance
where he is anticipated to speak and
make his views known at 8 15 local time
from Bedminster Tuesday evening